- Hello, I'm Bill Gates.
I've been hearing a lot of
crazy theories about me,
that I invented the coronavirus,
that I wanna inject you
all with tracking devices,
and I'm here to say that that's all true,
and much, much more.
♪ Bitch, I'm Bill Gates ♪
♪ Watch me pull up to the party ♪
♪ Open the doors and the hoes
hopping out the Bugatti ♪
♪ Walk in the place and
we cranking the bass ♪
♪ Making things Sheikh
like we in Abu Dhabi ♪
♪ Rock so much fur call
that shit a safari ♪
♪ Clad in the cloak
'cause I'm Illuminati ♪
♪ Corona ain't coming from Asia ♪
♪ I'm the sauce, teriyaki ♪
♪ I be in tight with the deep state ♪
♪ Do what I like, got a blank
check, buy me a clean slate ♪
♪ Hung out with Jeffrey
but when shit got messy ♪
♪ I hung him, now Jeffrey
ain't seeing release date ♪
♪ Hillary speed dial, we mates ♪
♪ Think that's all, please wait ♪
♪ How many other conspiracies are by me ♪
♪ (One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven)
At least eight ♪
♪ You know, that pimp with the gray hair ♪
♪ Got a side hustle sell kids on Wayfair ♪
♪ Couldn't care less 'cause
Bill never play fair ♪
♪ Grab a couple toddlers
straight from daycare ♪
♪ Not telling you again kid stay there ♪
♪ Make a pretty penny like Mayfair ♪
♪ 10k for a cabinet that's the place where ♪
♪ I keep 'em locked up
like they're Bertha in Jane Eyre ♪
♪ Bitch I'm Bill Gates ♪
♪ I'm on that lean like
the Tower of Pisa ♪
♪ Spreading 5G 'cause
the virus a feature ♪
♪ Making those trillions
'cause I'm reptilian ♪
♪ Me and the Queen, we are
both the same creature ♪
♪ New world order out in Geneva ♪
♪ Liking my ladies if they are Lolita ♪
♪ First name Bill, last name Gates ♪
♪ Bet you didn't know that
my middle name pizza ♪
By the way, I'm Q.
I'm behind everything crazy
that goes on in this world.
Why do I do it?
Why does anyone do anything?
All you need to know is you're a cuck.
♪ Bitch, I'm Bill Gates ♪
♪ Watch me pull up at your place ♪
♪ Parking the whip and
I hop out the wraith ♪
♪ One moment you're dad playing Xbox ♪
♪ And next thing I'm putting
the stick in your face ♪
♪ None of you haters is safe ♪
♪ All of you meeting the fate ♪
♪ Begging for mercy like wait ♪
♪ Arguing points like this shit a debate ♪
♪ I point at the base and empty the case ♪
♪ All y'all thought Bill was a has-been ♪
♪ So I'm back from the
lab with a vaccine ♪
♪ Injecting machines in your bloodstream ♪
♪ Eight billion tracked on
a flat screen, that's mean ♪
♪ Dammit, you're right ♪
♪ He got a tracking device ♪
♪ He grabbing your rights ♪
♪ Erasing them like he
formatting a drive, nice ♪
♪ And I be fucking your wife, what ♪
♪ Yeah, I be fucking your wife, THOT ♪
♪ Keeping her screaming at night, G-spot ♪
♪ Bill know the things
that she likes, hot ♪
♪ She looking fine in the jeans, Hackman ♪
♪ I be leaving my mark, Chapman ♪
♪ She be giving me jobs, Mac fan ♪
♪ I be taking her cherry, PAC-MAN ♪
♪ Give her that cream
like her name is Ganesha ♪
♪ She ain't Melinda so
I don't respect her ♪
♪ I'm the injector, give her the nectar ♪
♪ She screaming yes, like a broken Alexa ♪
♪ She liked the way that I choke her ♪
♪ Ever had a dick like this, no sir ♪
♪ I bust a nut and I ghost her ♪
♪ Bitch done on both
sides like a toaster ♪
♪ I come in her eye 'til
it's red like albino ♪
♪ Griping my dick like
that shit is a tightrope ♪
♪ Charging the pussy she call me a rhino ♪
♪ Call me Hitchcock, bitch I'm a maestro ♪
♪ Did it in the shower, psycho ♪
♪ Did it in the shower, hydro ♪
♪ My dick long like a slide show ♪
♪ Your dick, soft, micro ♪
(laughs) I'm just kidding.
Oh sorry, I have to take this.
(upbeat music)